[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's bring in Albert Breer
he's the Monday Morning Quarterback
Albert let me uh let me start with the
Broncos situation here trying to figure
out exactly who wants this job have they
offered this to anybody
I don't know if they formally offered it
to anybody I know they like to make
Orion's quite a bit
um obviously they've talked to Jim
Harbaugh multiple times I don't think
anybody should miss the Nuance to
tomorrow is national Signing Day so
you know you know how those things can
go sometimes sometimes college coaches
want to get past that before they
consider other things
um Dan Quinn was very much in the mix
before he pulled his name out and
decided um to stay in Dallas so you know
I think it's a combination of things you
know I I think you know Dan it's it's
the quarterback situation for sure and
it's the it's the contract you're going
to be saddled with you know but on top
of that it's it's also like
circumstances in each of these cases
this Harbaugh just want to stay at
Michigan if you're trying to use them to
get more money out of Michigan
um Dan Quinn you know is very happy in
Dallas and isn't desperate to take his
next swing at a head coaching job and
then demeko Ryan's has a place that you
know he played for for seven years
coming to get him you know so I think
it's you know a combination of the the
job not being perfect and then some
circumstances with the other coaches
um that has given those I would say each
of those other coaches have options if
that makes sense that's the danger in
going after coaches with options is they
might not pick you
if you were going to wager against Sean
Payton coaches in the NFL where he stays
in TV these days in TV for another year
um as at this point like an educated
guess I I think that the the biggest
problem for him was the two places that
I think were probably most desirable to
him geographically
had massive massive a massive
quarterback question
um and are you okay with Kyler Murray's
contractor are you okay with Russell
Wilson's contract to me that sort of the
Crux of the whole thing you know and
um because it's not one of these where
it's like okay well we'll see where how
it goes for the next year or so and then
I'll go get my own quarterback after
that if it doesn't work out in those
situations you're married to those
quarterbacks and Sean Payton I only have
one more swing at this so I think with
those situations that I think those
places have the geographic Advantage
because I think he wants to stay West
um you know I I think there was the the
the question of whether or not he wanted
to marry up with those quarterbacks and
then you know I think you look at a
Carolina you you look at um you know you
you look at a um
you know a Houston and how long are
those builds going to be how hard is it
going to be for you to find a
quarterback so I think he's comfortable
living in Manhattan Beach he's got a
comfortable television job
um and you know certainly I think with
only five open this year there stands to
be a whole lot a whole lot more options
in 2024. was Kellen Moore fired by the
Cowboys
I heard things weren't great between him
and Mike McCarthy at the end
um and you know I I don't know if it was
finally the fact that they were both
sort of play callers by trade that got
them or it was the way that Dak played
what I do know is like that that
Arrangement that I think had worked okay
but had its ups and downs over three
years had sort of run its course and
obviously there were some great
opportunities to be an offensive
coordinator Elsewhere for Kellen Moore
and I think this sort of allowed them to
come to a
uh everybody wins type of scenario where
you know Mike McCarthy can move on with
his own staff and as the play caller and
Kellen Moore can go find a place that
honestly like in a year could Vault him
into being a head coach
um and this is coming on the heels of
Kellen Moore doing really really well
interviewing with Carolina Panthers
where he does have some momentum so yeah
I just think it was sort of a
combination of one of those things
um I think that they came to the
decision a little while ago on this and
really since it's about Kellen Moore
finding his landing spot
um so they could make it look at least a
little bit more amenable than it was
he's Albert beer the Monday Morning
Quarterback the Aaron Rodgers report
that I'll put in quotations here
um
it almost now feels like it's fact that
the Packers want to move on from him
when Adam schefter is taking Collective
opinions around the league
which doesn't sound like those are
sources here help me understand the
Rogers situation how it's being reported
and where the Packers and Rogers stand
on this
I think Aaron Rodgers is at a personal
Crossroads and I think the Packers are
at an organizational Crossroads like I
think for Aaron he's at the point of his
career or Brett Favre was at the end and
remember what Aaron Rodgers witnessed
was the first three years of his career
it was like is Brett Favre going to get
off the tractor and come back from
Mississippi you know what I mean like
and he saw that and so I think you know
for Rogers my guess would be and this is
a guess but my guess would be
like he wants to get separated from a
little bit before he decides what he
wants to do meanwhile the Packers have
to decide whether or not they want to go
forward with this Arrangement when
they've got a major decision coming on
their younger quarterback and you know I
think it's May 2nd they have to make a
decision on his fifth year option and
that's I think a 22 23 million dollar
decision and that locks you into Jordan
love for 2024. so if you pick up that
option you're basically saying Jordan
love is going to be our starting
quarterback maybe not in 23 but
definitely a 24. and if you've come to
that conclusion you just pull the plug
now do you think it's time to turn over
some of the roster to fix some of the
cap problems you've got some guys you've
got to resign like Rashawn Gary who's
going to be coming off of an ACL so like
organizationally I think that the
Packers have sort of come to that
natural point after three years of Love
on the bench the same way they came to
that natural turning the page point in
2008 where Aaron Rodgers had been
sitting on the bench for three years
where it's do we want to go all in with
Rogers for the next cup couple of years
knowing that he he might be all in he
might not
and just continue to load our roster up
and then start over when we start over
or is it time to turn the page now and I
think the idea turning the page has more
Merit Than People realize yeah I agree I
I would have turned the page the year
before and moved on if I thought Jordan
love could play and you just move on
from the drama here I damn Dan the one
thing I would mention I think that they
feel better about a lot better about
Jordan love today than they felt like a
year ago you know what I mean well I
think that's what makes it different why
I think he's made real progress this
year now I'm not saying he's gonna be a
superstar and I'm not saying he's gonna
be Aaron Rodgers in 2008 but I do think
like there was I think there was some
genuine concern over where Jordan love
was a year ago at this point I think
they feel a little bit better about him
now okay
the 49ers situation we had a Dr Mark
addicts who is a orthopedic surgeon
played in the NFL and uh talked to him
about the Brock Purdy injury and he
voiced surprised that this six-month
time frame for Purdy to be able to come
back he said you know this is a year
this is Tommy John's surgery this is
maybe nine months but not six months and
maybe it's a year do you think the
Niners open the door for the possibility
of Tom Brady
I think they investigate it yes the door
was open last year Dan
um you know and I think to some degree
for John Lynch and Kyle Shanahan you
have to look at like where they are with
their roster how close they've been
three NFC Title Games in four years and
if you can just get good not great
quarterback play and I think you can get
that out of Tom Brady and you can get a
quarterback who can perform in the
biggest moments which nobody's ever been
better at that than Tom Brady
then you should be the same favorite to
win the Super Bowl just based on where
they are from a roster standpoint so
that door was open last year and I think
for that six week period where Brady was
um where Brady was
considering his options quote unquote
retired right
um a lot of people talked about Miami
San Francisco left the door cracked
during that time too and so you know I
think that there was this feeling there
on Brady's camp
do we have to go back to Tampa or is
there a possibility to go Miami is there
a possibility to force our way to San
Francisco and Tampa slammed the door
shut on that their messaging was really
strong through February you know and
then they they pushed it to the
beginning of free agency he said and
said your inner you're out and this
team's gonna look a lot different if
you're not in and he jumped in
I I think because the Niners went
through that top thought process the
same way the Dolphins did over that six
or seven weeks last year I think the
door is open uh I don't know if Brady's
gonna want to live on the other side of
the country from his kids like to me
like I think that's the biggest wild
card in that whole thing because he's
got two kids in Miami and another in New
York but I certainly think the Niners
are going to leave the door open to this
especially with what happened with Brock
Purdy what are the Dolphins options
given to us still in concussion protocol
after five weeks it's hard because you
know I just mentioned that natural point
that the Packers have reached with
Jordan loved the dolphins are there with
Tua also so they got to make a decision
on his fifth year option by the first
week of May
and if you don't pick up his fifth year
option then you're necessarily in a
year-to-year situation with your
quarterback because his contract's going
to be up after this year and if you look
at the history of it and since the
system went in place in 2011 where first
round picks had the four-year deal is a
fifth year option quarterbacks who don't
get their fifth year option picked up
are almost never on the team after that
you know and so the same way the Packers
are sort of at a cross towards in a
decision point with Jordan loved the
Dolphins are right there with Tua and
what they did last year was so much of
it was based on getting an answer onto
assigning to Ron Armstead trading for
Tyreek Hill hiring Mike McDaniel all
that was about finding getting a clear
answer on who Tua is and I think they do
have a clear idea of who he is I think
he can be a good starting quarterback
and Lee I think they believe that the
question's the medical now yeah and I I
think it's really hard when a guy's had
that many injury problems let alone like
a concussion issue because he was
injured a lot before the concussion
thing can you can you really go all in
on a guy like that it's a really really
tough thing and I think it's going to be
something the Dolphins are going to have
to wrestle with for the next few weeks
as they set out their plan for their off
season and what else they're going to do
a quarterback
always great to talk to you thank you
Albert all right thanks Dan Albert Maria
the Monday Morning Quarterback